Al this is the moment that Venezuela's
president close Ally Alex Sab got off a
plane in kakas on Wednesday the
Colombian businessman was freed from a
US prison in Miami in exchange for the
release of 10 Americans jailed by the
Venezuelan regime and the extradition of
a fugitive defense
contractor as part of the deal kak has
also released at least 13 Venezuelan
political Prisoners the deal brokered by
Qatar is the largest release of American
prisoners in Venezuela's
history it comes weeks after US
President Joe Biden's Administration
agreed to suspend oil sanctions on
Venezuela following a commitment by
Venezuelan president Nicolas Maduro to
work towards free and fair presidential
elections in
2024 earlier in the day Biden said the
deal was a step in the right direction
we have no higher priority than the
release of the Tain and or hostage
Americans being held hosti in addition
to that Venezuela thus far is keeping
their commitment toward the democratic
election not over yet they've made
detailed commitments we'll see if they
hold them but many in the region see the
release of Alex Sab as a major
concession to Maduro sahab was arrested
on money laundering and other criminal
charges in 20120 and was regarded as a
key tool against the regime standing
Side by side with Sab the Venezuelan
president celebrated his release in
karakas calling for the normalization of
relations with
Washington showing respect everything
can be achieved with mutual respect can
advance towards a different phase in our
relationship hopefully some analysts
believe this deal allows both sides to
show that however difficult their
negotiations are
working this agreement guarantees that
the Doha and Barbados agreement remain
in place it buys time to maintain the
oil and gas licenses with the US that
the US had threatened to withdraw
there's no doubt that the deal will
anger maduro's political opponents but
in the end it could prove to be a
win-win for everyone involved Biden gets
to bring safely home the US prisoners
while Maduro shows that he's still in
charge and that he's willing to do
anything it takes to save those in his
close Circle strengthening his position
before next year's presidential
elections Alexander RTI Al jaaz
bot make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer